valérie pécresse elle comme c'est
quelqu'un de sérieux elle dit ce qu'elle
fait et elle fera ce qu'elle dit elle ne
fait pas de fausses promesses
démagogiques sur sur ces questions là
qui encore une fois sont essentiels pour
le quotidien des français le projet de
valérie pécresse est celui qui est le
plus chiffre est le plus sérieux le plus
crédible pour restaurer l'autorité de
l'état comme on le disait à l'instant
pour réduire la dette et améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la seule
d'ailleurs qu' un projet qui propose
également des économies il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui notre état est en
faillite on a trois mille milliards de
dettes 3000 milliards de dettes et que
quand on regarde l'inflation des
dépenses qui sont proposés par des
candidats comme jean luc mélenchon ou
marine le pen on est effaré est la seule
qui pour le coup est un projet justement
qui prenne en compte cette situation
parce que cet endettement un moment
donné enfin il va falloir en payer le
prix et donc
elle elle propose justement sur ces
questions aussi de pouvoir d'achat des
des réponses qui sont concrètes comme je
le disais et qui s'inscrivent dans la
durée